JAMES ANDERSON:
Revolutionary developments
in the union of chemistry
and physics hold
the key to solving
unprecedented global problems.
But understanding the central role
that chemistry and technical forces
play in addressing these
problems requires learning
the fundamental scientific concepts.
Join me to learn the
foundations of chemistry,
ranging from molecular structures
and thermodynamics, to entropy,
and equilibria to electrochemistry and
how to apply these scientific concepts
to our modern world.
Throughout each course,
you will not only
gain quantitative reasoning
and critical thinking skills,
but also, will be able to
directly link scientific concepts
to current global strategies
on energy production
and use in the context of rapid changes
in the Earth's climate structure.
These courses can be taken
together for college credit
through edX's MicroBachelors programs.
Learn chemistry while earning
college credit for your future.
Chemistry can change the world.
Are you ready to shape the future?